all right ready gather around here we go
everybody
okay everyone hello it is time for
Drew's News podcast or the Drew's News
podcast I guess you should say where
we're serving up all the news you need a
Sprinkle of Pop Culture a splash of
inspiration and always a side of good
feels today we're covering everything
from the best cities for a girls trip to
engagement boners yes they are a thing
and do we have the best guest in the
world here today I mean literally Aubry
Plaza is here
apparently at like all nightclubs right
now there's like major remixes of that
song that is the thing sweeping the club
Sig is the White Lotus theme song it
gives me so much anxiety it gives me so
much anxiety and like I love it and yet
I have a panic attack every single year
I've been into my it's been in my head
for weeks I have nightmares I mean
nightmares but it's so good because not
to drop a name but Quentin Tarantino
what said you should either have opening
credits or closing credits really and I
said I think I'm a closing credit and
he's like no I'm opening credits because
it's mood time it is mood time it really
does you settle in I mean did you see
tar I haven't okay never mind but it's
it's should I is it good I mean kid fun
I know and I could watch her watch
people cry and I love Todd field God she
takes such a big swing you're just like
God you're taking a big swing I love
watching her she's like it's like
watching an animal in the zoo
um but anyway watching them in the niche
yeah and there she goes wearing her suit
conducting the orchestra in Berlin and
uh then she popped up um but she the
opening of that movie is like it's it
actually takes it way too way too far
the Tarantino thing it takes much time
just get to the movie but I anyway well
speaking of mood our first story it's
really interesting because a minute ago
we were talking about Prosthetics and
men and you know we were oh right penile
penis situations so check out this story
that was totally news to me pun intended
engagement boners Cosmo magazine reports
that men are popping the question as
well as popping a boner and it's going
viral apparently men get so turned on at
the idea of popping the question and
like the whole thing it's so funny I
would have so assumed it was the
opposite like it was a shrinkage moment
like if they they shrink and you like it
just seems like you're talking about
like life and all that you're gonna like
tackle together this is not real no one
has a boner when they're engaging that's
what I thought but apparently this is a
thing what is engagement boners I don't
believe it I don't believe it either I
feel like it's so heady thank you
do you think do you think your man was
excited what do you think your man was
excited when he asked you to marry him
or was he like I'm living in this
beautiful romantic moment thinking about
our future and not like I don't remember
I'm not allowed to say all right but you
know looking at you and being as in love
with you as I am I would do the same so
yeah it's true all right up next travel
and Leisure just dropped the 10 best
cities
um in the U.S for a girls trip they
include New Orleans Miami Austin
Charleston South Carolina boo no I'm
kidding I have nothing against
do you have a favorite city for a girls
trip or did any of these ring a bell
okay I have a new city that I just
learned about it's called serenbee and
it's in Georgia and it's a Wellness
Community what you would love it I heard
that Shirley MacLean went one time oh my
God I want to go I love anything which
surely does exactly I want to do out on
a limb and all her books and I'd like
just I remember the Charlene McLean past
lives past lives Pavilion okay if you
went to the Past lives Pavilion who do
you think would pop up wait what is that
do you remember the movie Defending Your
Life without oh yes yes yes Shirley
MacLaine is oh my God past lives
Pavilion and of course Meryl Streep is
Prince Valiant and God Albert Brooks is
you know I don't hear it man running
like what does it mean when someone pops
up
like you were that person once in your
life right
I feel like I have some weird connection
to Scandinavia like maybe I was like
some kind of like Scandinavian like Sea
Hag
or like a I'm picturing Marty Feldman
the comedian that has the very large
eyes who is in all the Mel Brooks movie
are you sure yeah
um and you're thinking Scandinavian sea
which I think this says a lot about us
okay great but I still think we make a
great team me too okay okay we'll be
right back with more everything be right
back
welcome back okay up next it was a real
Planes Trains and Automobiles moment for
13 strangers when their flight was
canceled instead of waiting two days for
the next flight of which it was you know
that was the only flight they rented a
15 passenger van and hit the road
together their 10-hour drive from
Orlando Florida to Knoxville Tennessee
made them
fast friends and viral Sensations so
would you get in a passenger van full of
strangers and drive
I'm so curious about humans me too yeah
I would be into it I had a moment Aubry
where uh I think it was last Christmas I
was just you know I felt like I had been
pushing so hard with the pandemic and
the kids and the show and life and
everybody has just had so much tension
and anxiety and you know abnormal
circumstances for the last few years and
I I went into an ocean and I cried and I
said God I'm praying and begging for an
answer to how I keep like the good fight
going yeah and my answer was I love
people yes that was my true my truth
people love you by the way but I I think
that is the truth that is the truth
we're on this planet the thing that
distinguishes you know the human species
from other animals is our connection to
each other our socialization our our
friendships our our connection to each
other this is why I believe in
theatrical releases and communal viewing
and yes
um and communal anything because that's
what distinguishes us from the rest of
the species it's it's our connection to
each other we would not exist without
a curiosity about each other I believe
that too and we are looking for a
collective experience yeah and the
Internet is just taking us down man it's
isolating us so which is ironic because
you know the joke is we've never been
more connected but are we and yet you
know we are like I don't I'm worried I
don't look out the car window at the
life passing me by I use that
opportunity to like check a few boxes on
the phone which I put down for 12 hours
a day yeah and if I go on vacation or I
take a minute off I really do shut my
phone off that's good and then I fail
and I start texting about work stuff but
like but at least you try I mean it's
really hard to it's really hard to shut
off I do although I'm that person who's
like everybody you will not hear from me
like I trust and believe in the process
you guys are so amazing I can't believe
I get to work alongside of like everyone
and I love you and I'm sorry but like I
know you get it I'm just gonna like cut
cut out and peace out for a few days ago
like 10 minutes later 10 minutes later
you're like wait what no I'm serious
like it's I make these very large
decrees and what's so embarrassing is I
don't last and the focus thing is so
cool now because you can be like do not
disturb but you're like I'm looking at
everything and you know it by the way
the last thing I wrote was so bananas it
was like listen everyone I just have to
shut off for a few days because I'm
taking a message like a group text no I
was like my auto reply because you can
auto click on your email no text I
figured out how to I reply with text and
I was like I'm taking a mental Wellness
break and I just really need it but I
will be back and I'm wishing everyone
who texts me like the very best and it
just sounded so
that's my dream it sounded like just too
much it's not so I just wrote I'm off my
phone I'll be back in a few days yeah
and it was like one of the few times
I've actually edited myself what would
your auto reply say
um my auto reply would be like
um
sorry not sorry I don't know I don't
know I don't have a I don't know I don't
have I don't even know how to do that
I'm sorry I'm like a boomer with my
phone like I'm really I'll show you how
to do it because if I I'm not just a
boomer I'm a Luddite and if I can figure
it out anybody could figure I hate my
phone I wanna
um like I actually when I fell the other
day I was telling you I fell on the
ground like I fell like my phone also
fell in like a gutter or something and
I'm waiting for the day where it just
explodes I hate it I think I'm hoping
that like there will be a revolt and we
will like distance ourselves to
education don't you feel like so
energized when you're not on your phone
like it's very addictive
um last get ready for cuteness overload
an Intrepid young girl in La named
Madeline asked for and was granted a
license to own a unicorn puppy
wait nope this is your thing unicorn no
unicorn yeah you go this is our thing
there is no my or eye it's ours and we
that's right she asked for permission to
own a unicorn and the Los Angeles Animal
Control had a few caveats for unicorn
ownership they said the Unicorn must get
plenty of sunlight Moon beams and
rainbows its horn must be polished once
a week wow
um any glitter given to it must be a
non-toxic uh glitter and it requires to
be fed watermelon of course Madeline
Madeline needs to find the Unicorn first
um but I love that the Los Angeles like
animal control actually like fed into
this and helped this little girl's
fantasy be realized me too why not I
mean what is the fantasies are all we
have to say about that the Christmas
witch the latest installment of the
Christmas witch thank you so much the
Christmas witch agrees
children's books that I love so much
thank you drew and I've hung out with
the Christmas witch so I feel like yeah
she has been here
um no the Christmas witch agrees you
know reindeers are the same you know
reindeers love to eat glitter
so we feed reindeers the same in fact
when I was a child I would go um
sprinkle glitter on the lawn for
reindeer food and I believe in that and
I still believe in it to this day so
unicorns are unicorns and reindeers are
friends
see Madeline if you ever hear this you
have an ally yes in unicorn dumb and I
loved this story so much and I just
thought because of you you know we have
to tell it it's and and we like a range
of news yeah you know we covered many
different subjects hard-hitting news yes
glitter news yes exactly
um an all ages newscast if I may say so
myself maybe one of the most widespread
all ages podcast we've ever done here
the woman after my own heart four
quadrants baby tent Poles get them all
it's like literally get them all
get them all in here what female like
I'm gonna direct a movie or quadrant
movie I'm so excited about your movie
for the kids you're going to be a female
Tim Burton and if there's anybody that
has the imagination the hutzpah the
Moxie and the wherewithal to carry that
torch it's you shut up
um we'll see I mean I'm gonna do my best
but I I love a I love a big movie I love
a big movie you know I love a movie that
everyone can enjoy I agree and I know
everyone thinks I'm gonna make some
weird creepy Murder movie where I'm sure
whatever but it's like it's not me you
know I'm for the kids
you are for everybody you're an all ages
party and everyone's invited okay right
I'm G rated basically
I I want like G to like at like R like I
want I want it all and I think the
hardest comedy for I'm developing
actually a cartoon right now for
six-year-olds and I've been trying to
write jokes you know for the show and
it's honestly harder to write jokes for
six-year-olds than it is for adults it's
harder you have to get into their brain
I don't have children but like that's a
harder Challenge and I'm up for it I've
written my postcards to my girls
um for many many years and when they go
to Camp I write them each a postcard
every day and each postcard has a joke
on it two jokes a day so they don't get
the same material
um so if you ever need a dream Mom I
wish you were my mom be my mommy I well
I I'll say the same thing to you feed me
back in my belly feed me put me to bed I
will I will I know by the way I'm good
at it too I will like and I I always
like hold and like they get in the nook
of my arms nurture me hold them and I
pet them nourish me yes oh God what I
wouldn't do to put you to bed
I'm a hungry baby
and I have everything you know you do I
really do I know you do you know I like
to end the podcast by suggesting to
people how to pass along the fact that
the podcast is happening I've said you
know if maybe you see a cat you could
tell the cat or like if you pass by a
tree you could tell the tree but who
would you tell like how to pass the word
along for the podcast or what the Mr Mr
Conductor
the man on the train
um is that God sure okay I would tell
everybody in my dreams fantasies and
delusions if you're having a dream tell
that person in your dream you can
communicate with people telepathically
in the information yeah the unconscious
world is another dimension that we've
just yet to tap into see I knew you
would bring it to a whole new realm and
you did if you're dreaming pass it by
you know someone in your dreams and
spread the word and speaking of Dreams
mine is coming true right now by being
with you mine too mommy yeah get into
the Nook get back in my belly oh it
feels good oh God it's so warm so warm
the perfect temperature not too hot not
too hot not too cold for my mom and food
on tap 24 7. I'll prep to put you out in
that big big big world
well for everybody listening out there
please be safe pass the word along and
make the dreams that you have a reality
by being next to someone that you think
is just the greatest on the planet
thank you so much